У запалі передвиборчих перегонів кандидатка у президенти Юлія Тимошенко
пообіцяла запровадити обов’язкове медичне страхування за рахунок коштів роботодавців
з одночасним зменшенням удвічі податкового навантаження на них.
Чим викликала, м'яко кажучи, подив
у виконувачки обов'язків міністра охорони здоров'я України Уляни Супрун.
Та назвала це "популістським міфом" і "страховою фантазією",
що стане непідйомним тягарем для бізнесу та стимулом "іти ще глибше в тінь".
Уляна Супрун стверджує, що безкоштовного страхування не існує,
і є модель, коли за нього платять як роботодавці, так і самі працівники.
Як приклад навела Німеччину. Ось, як це працює.
Медичне страхування громадян у Німеччині побудоване на принципах соціальної солідарності -
"один за всіх і всі за одного".
Зародилася така система ще за часів канцлера Бісмарка наприкінці 19-го століття.
Розрахунок був простий: працевлаштовані громадяни
платять внески в касу медичного страхування,
яка фінансує лікування усіх співгромадян.
Зокрема й тих, які самі не можуть платити внески - дітей, пенсіонерів та безробітних.
Це і є принцип соціальної солідарності.
Медична страховка коштує в Німеччині приблизно 15 відсотків від заробітку.
Працівник і роботодавець сплачують ці внески навпіл.
Гроші надходять у спеціальний державний фонд,
який далі розподіляє їх за медичними страховими компаніями
відповідно до кількості застрахованих у них громадян, а також до обсягу послуг.
Нині в Німеччині налічується загалом 110 компаній медичного страхування.
90 відсотків німців застраховані у державних страхових компаніях,
лише 10 відсотків - у приватних.
Обов'язкове страхування охоплює найнеобхідніші медичні послуги:
амбулаторне і стаціонарне лікування, необхідні хірургічні операції, деякі стоматологічні послуги.
Натомість, перелік послуг приватних страхових компаній
варіюється в залежності від індивідуальних побажань і умов договору
і може включати в себе, наприклад, альтернативну медицину,
протезування зубів або лікування на курорті.
Однак приватну страховку можуть дозволити собі лише німці з високою зарплатою.
Право обирати між приватною та державною лікарняною касою нині мають лише ті,
хто заробляє "брутто" понад 60 тисяч євро на рік або понад 5 тисяч євро на місяць.
Вартість приватної страховки не залежить від заробітку,
а вираховується залежно від віку, статі, стану здоров'я клієнта
та обсягу послуг, які він хоче отримувати.
У Німеччині 99 відсотків громадян мають медичне страхування.
Більшість пацієнтів навіть не замислюються і не знають, скільки коштує
та чи інша медична послуга - просто простягаєш картку страхування на стійці реєстрації і все.
Лікарі отримують свої гонорари не від пацієнтів, а від медичних страхових компаній.
80 тисяч євро - середня річна зарплата лікаря у ФРН "брутто".
Розмір гонорарів не довільний - його встановлює асоціація лікарів і лікарняних кас.
Загалом жителі Німеччини довіряють медичній системі країни.
За статистикою, 86 відсотків респондентів задоволені послугами,
які надає їхня медична страховка.
Вона дає їм право ходити до будь-якого лікаря і скільки завгодно.
Відповідно німці частіше за інших європейців звертаються до лікарів -
в середньому, 17 разів на рік.
І беруть лікарняні у середньому 12 днів у році. А чому б і ні?
Адже за все заплачено! Правда, платниками страхових внесків.